- All right, I like to top up each hour
with a little extra helping of happiness.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
All right there's one
guest we've had on the show
more than anyone, y'all, to date,
lifestyle pro, fashion guru podcast host,
and my friend Lawrence Zarian
has joined us dozens of times.
I don't even know how many times.
He truly wants to make
people feel beautiful
and wonderful in all the ways.
That's the spirit behind
his new exclusive fashion collection,
which is available starting today.
Everybody, welcome back Lawrence!
(audience cheering)
- Hi everybody!
This is such a big day.
- I'm going under.
- Such a big day.
- It's a big day!
You smell good.
- Thank you.
- So this collection you've
been planning for a long time.
- It is 30 years in the making.
And I will say this,
I'm probably having my
own American Idol moment.
- I love it.
- Because I feel like everything
I've done has led me to this place.
And I have done makeovers
for the last 30 years.
And for the last 30 years,
women have told me exactly
what is missing when it comes to fashion.
So I listened.
And this collection,
Beautiful by Lawrence Zarian,
exclusively at QVC is basically a tribute
inspired to all those women.
It's gonna be cheesy,
but I've waited a
lifetime for this moment.
- I love it, that's not cheesy.
Wonderful.
(clapping)
Well we have models here with some looks
from Beautiful by Lawrence Zarian.
- [Lawrence] Okay, first of
all, let's start with Morgan.
- [Kelly] I love it.
(audience cheering)
- And a jumpsuit is one and done.
And I put her in my crimson red,
V-neck, flutter sleeve, lux knit jumpsuit.
- [Kelly] She's cute.
- [Lawrence] And the best part,
ladies pay attention.
Pockets number one,
(crowd cheering)
- [Kelly] Love pockets.
- And number two, it is
an adjustable waistline.
So women can move the waistline
to celebrate their unique
body, their unique shape,
and their unique size.
- And your night out
when you drink too much.
- This is one and done.
You can dress this up,
you can dress it down.
And this comes in such
a celebration of colors.
Black, Navy, and Crimson Red.
- Okay, right on.
I love the red one.
- [Lawrence] Also, machine washable.
You're welcome!
(audience cheering and clapping)
- All right, what's next?
- All right, next up, that is Maddie
and the slack is back.
I put her in my mountain
green, wide leg trouser pant.
And here's the thing that I
love about the trouser pant,
because with the waistband,
I added adjustable tabs
to give women the freedom of sizing.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- It comes in an assortment of colors.
And then I layered on my luxe lace top.
And what I love about my lace blouse is
I called it the Doris, inspired by my mom,
'cause my mom loved lace.
And then finally,
Sophie does have a choice.
And I picked my favorite piece.
And this is my favorite
piece of the collection.
And what I've done with my collection
is there are certain people in my life
that have changed my life,
and have inspired my life.
And if I didn't have
amazing women in my life,
like the women at QVC, I wouldn't be here.
So this piece is officially
called the Kelly Cardigan.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly exclaiming)
Come on, come here.
- I didn't know you were going to-
this is so cute!
Buy this one!
- Long sleeve, ribbed.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Open front,
flyaway cardigan.
- And it comes in four beautiful colors.
- [Kelly] I have a cardigan.
- And every time you
want to put something on
that feels something, put on the cardigan,
that will be your wardrobe-
- [Kelly] I'm cozy, yeah.
- I love, that's so sweet.
- [Lawrence] I love you.
- This is awesome.
Thank you so much, Lawrence.
I'm liking his post right now.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Everyone be sure to check out.
Beautiful by Lawrence
Zarian exclusively on QVC.
Specifically my cardigan.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Usually though, at this point in the show,
we give our guests a thousand dollars,
courtesy of our seasonal
sponsor, Frixion by Pilot pens,
makers of the go-to erasable
pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
So usually we give a
thousand dollars away.
But today, I think you're doing alright.
So that's, we're gonna give
it to someone in the audience.
How does that sound?
Anybody want a thousand dollars?
(crowd cheering and clapping)
Well I want you all look at that monitor
and our cameras are gonna work their magic
and one of your faces is
gonna pop up right there.
Let's do it!
(crowd cheering and clapping)
(drumming music)
What's your name?
- Janice Taylor.
Thank you.
- Well, thank you so much for coming.
I hope you enjoy the thousand dollars.
- Thank you.
- A big thank you to Garth Brooks
for hanging out with us all hour.
We love him so much.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, try and change it.